IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
NOW...
YOU'VE NOTICED SPONSORS RUNNING
FROM THE NETWORK LIKE CHILDREN
RUNNING FROM THE BEACH AFTER
SEEING A FIN IN THE WATER--
THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S SHART WEEK
ON COMEDY CENTRAL!
(ONE PERSON CLAPS ONCE)
THAT ONE CLAP IS ABOUT WHAT THAT
DESERVES. UH...
(LAUGHTER)
WE'VE BEEN CELEBRATING ALL WEEK
LONG WITH... WITH SHART TAGS,
AND, UH, WE'RE GONNA GO OUT WITH
A SQUIRT.
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS...
SHARTTOYS. SHARTTOYS.
(AUDIENCE GROANING)
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE: CRAP YOUR
PANTS ELMO!
OR LINCOLN LOGS.
(LAUGHTER, GROANS)
OR SORRY... ABOUT MY PANTS.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, AND GO!
YES, STEVE AGEE.
>> SLIP IN SHIT 'N SLIDE.
>> HARDWICK: YES! (LAUGHING)
POINTS. MEGAN.
>> PLOP-IT.
>> HARDWICK: YEP, GOOD. POINTS.
DOUG.
>> UH, SPEAK & SMELL.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. POINTS.
YES, MEGAN.
>> SILLY POOPY.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. YEAH, YEAH.
YOU CAN MASH IT ONTO A COMIC
STRIP AND IT... YEAH, I'LL GIVE
YOU THAT. POINTS.
YEAH, I LIKE THAT. DOUG.
>> LOWER G.I. JOE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: SO GOOD.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT COMES OUT?
COBRA!
POINTS TO DOUG. STEVE.
>> HOT STEAMING WHEELS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
GODDAMN IT. DOUG.
>> PADDINGTON BEAR SHITS IN THE
WOODS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> AND WILL FUCK YOU UP.
>> HARDWICK: AND WILL FUCK YOU
UP. POINTS. POINTS. MEGAN.
>> SHARTS AGAINST HUMANITY.
>> HARDWICK: YES! EXCELLENT!
POINTS. NICE. MEGAN.
>> UH, STRAWBERRY SHARTCAKE.
>> HARDWICK: YES! GOOD! POINTS.
AND HER HAIR SMELLS LIKE...
>> SHARTS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. OKAY, GOOD.
POINTS. STEVE.
>> AND STRAWBERRIES.
>> RAINBOW SHITE.
>> HARDWICK: OH, SO GOOD!
YEAH, POINTS.